after four years in prison and one year
under house arrest
nazanin zagari radcliffe's ordeal looks
like it's almost over
on sunday her electronic ankle tag was
removed
but she's not yet completely free
halloya said he doesn't know if she will
be allowed to leave iran
while welcoming the developments the
british prime minister criticized iran's
treatment of her
nazanin holds dual iranian british
citizenship
she had gone to iran with her young
daughter in april 2016 to visit her
parents
on the day she was meant to travel back
to the uk she was apprehended by members
of the iranian revolutionary guard at
the haran airport
she was sentenced to five years for
plotting to overthrow the iranian
government
evidence against naznen has never been
made public her trial
was held behind closed doors and she's
always maintained her innocence
the lack of transparency around her case
has led some to believe
that iran may have other motives for
holding on to her
the people who are in the iranian regime
are
absolutely paranoid about the west about
america about britain you know it's big
satan little satan
they think that we will stop at nothing
until there is regime change
and it is frankly very very hard to get
them to
to trust us and so that that is the
challenge of trying to deal with them
iran wants the uk to return money it
paid for tanks it purchased in 1976 but
never received
iran denies that nazanin's case is
linked to the ongoing dispute
given kind of the sensitivities around
this case even kind of the media
interest
that in this case the islamic republic
sees this
effectively as an opportunity it sees it
kind of as a bargaining chip
to be able to kind of put more pressure
certainly on britain in order
to get kind of more advantageous nazanin
has been summoned to court on march 14th
to face further charges of spreading
propaganda against iran
her husband richard has led her campaign
for release from the start
and throughout it all the daughter
gabriela has been counting the days
until her mother is freed asad beg
al-jazeera
tehran